[Music]
22 1928
e4 c5 and let's see how the smith mora
holds up at this level now
again those people watching on youtube
i've been playing the smith mora in the
speed run i don't really
i don't really know the smith more all
that well myself so i've been winging it
which has been a lot of fun
what i do have
as of a couple of weeks ago i ordered
this book i'm not going to look at it
now obviously that would be cheating
uh that would be cheating but
i do now have mayhem and the mora so
we can consult the book
after the game assuming that black takes
on c3 which is the accepted smith mora
okay just a second
okay i hear the right sound because i'm
turning the ac on i hear the perfect
sound d takes e3
and we will indeed get a chance
to play the accepted smith mora
d6 okay so d6 is just one of like many
many possible moves it doesn't really
contain a lot of independent value
because normally black follows up by
playing knight c6 or knight f6
and if you paid attention to the
previous myth warrior games in the speed
run you know that the light squad bishop
belongs in such positions
on
the c4 square you basically want to
provoke black into playing e6
which would create the sort of savannah
chevan and pawn structure and lead to
some of the main lines of the smith mora
so as far as i remember the move here is
bishop c4
yeah i've heard amazing things about
mayhem and the moral it's it's just
terrific analysis all around
and i think it it's just good as a as an
instructional book because it's so full
of ideas e6
oh and look who's in the chat
look who's in the chat
um mark himself the author himself is in
the chat gifting a sub
and now i'm gonna make a fool of myself
in front of you know the leading expert
so mark says knight f3 first almost
always except maybe if early a6
threatening or eb5 so
i stand corrected
according to mark you actually want to
start with knight f3 and maybe we can
delve into the reasons why
after the game but after e6 we
essentially transpose to the main line
by playing knight f3
okay
so now we got the man himself we got to
bring our a game
ah yeah that idea i'm familiar with with
bishop c4 queen b3 so knight c6 okay so
now
i suppose that we castle
and then of course we have the typical
smithmore idea of queen e2 rook d1
so let's castle let's continue our
development
kavita with the five subs
we got a lot of action here in the chat
bishop e7 okay so
the order in which our opponent is
developing is a little bit odd i don't
think it's really impacting the uh the
position itself
and here i think is a good moment to
implement
the very typical idea by which we start
applying pressure on black's center
the queen is not the most effective
piece to attack d6
what we want is to have not a queen on
d1 but a rook on d1 because that would
x-ray black's queen and that would
create all sorts of threats like e5 and
bishop f4 bishop t bishop takes d6 and
so that's where the typical regrouping
comes from we play queen e2 and then we
play rook d1
okay queen e2 knight f6 rook d1 and we
are already threatening the move e4 e5
um and a lot of people as far as i know
miss this okay so here black plays e5
himself
i think this is actually the correct
move and embarrassingly enough i don't
totally remember what white's response
is i think it might be bishop e3
i think it might be bishop e3
so we just want to continue our
development casually
let's get our bishop out yep and mark
confirms that the move is bishop e3 and
i do remember that there's this idea of
going before in these positions to
distract the knight from before and then
take on e5 but i don't think it's the
move here
i think the move is just rook ac1
and if black plays bishop e6
then we take on e6 and go b4
and mark says that h3 is not necessary
in this position in these positions
um
because bishop g4 isn't really that
inherently dangerous there is no real
easy way to put more pressure on the
knight
okay so let's get this rook into the
game with rook ac1 we have now completed
our development all of our pieces are in
the game
and this is really the heart of the
smith moore or this position so bishop
b6
and mark shared
the interesting principle that you don't
really take on e6 unless it wins
material unless you have something
concrete as a follow-up and here i think
is a great idea
is a great moment to apply
this idea of going b4
so we go b4 and the point is that if
knight takes b4 then we take on e6
and we have i think either knight takes
e5 or queen c4 we'll have to cross that
bridge when we get there black plays
knight g4 thank you dan kama for the
five subs
okay so this move i already don't know
so so now we're basically on our own
which is sort of exciting my
understanding of this position will be
tested now knight g4 hits the bishop
and at least intuitively
at least intuitively i would want to
keep this bishop so what comes to my
mind as kind of unsexy as this move
looks is just bishop e3 to d2
because later on we could chase the
knight away with h3 so
i feel like bishop d2
makes the most sense to me let's drop
our bishop back and i'm not too worried
about like knight d4 in this position
thank you anonymous for the thousand
bits
we got tons of support
here all right knight back to f6 so our
opponent is not against the draw very
high level play by black here very very
high level play and
okay probably the engine
will recommend that white repeats moves
here but of course we want to play for a
win so maybe we can find something other
than bishop e3 i do have one idea which
is to play and mark also played bishop
d2 which is to play bishop d2 to g5
right e3 is not the only square for the
bishop i don't love g5 as a development
square because we're not really
intending to take on f6 but it's the
only other square other than e3 so
i feel like this is better than nothing
so let's try bishop g5 and see how black
responds to this
okay bishop g4
ah very impressive bishop g4 threatens
knight d4
bishop g4 threatens knight d4
which is now a very serious threat
because it would essentially ruin our
king's side
ah the game was bishop d2 knight takes
before
wow
yeah we'll look at that after the game
we'll look at that line i think in this
position we actually have to go back to
e3 at this point
i think at this point we have to go back
to e3 at this point or we have to play
h3 but h3 there is still 94.
so let's go back to e3 the plus side of
this
is that black no longer has the move
knight before because now he's got a
bishop there
um now he's got a bishop there
okay knight takes b4
so that's the second pawn
that's the second pawn but the good news
is that we can win that pawn back either
by playing rook b1 which i don't like as
much or and we have to speed up a little
bit let's play the move h3 and pose a
little dilemma to this bishop if bishop
takes f3 then we're playing two pawns
down but we have the light squared
bishop if the bishop moves i was going
to say that we have knight takes c5 but
i completely miss bishop d7 so our
opponent is currently outplaying us
and uh we're gonna have to play two
pawns down but i still think i've got a
lot of compensation here let's play a3
to chase the knight away
let's play a3 to chase the knight away
okay
and now
let me think for a second i know that
queen a2 is a pretty typical idea in
such positions but black has this move
knight a5
yeah no i'm uh
not too impressed with
the the path that this game has followed
um
let me think for a second but knight b5
gives up e4 so somehow whichever move we
make
whichever move we make uh
there's some sort of a downside to it
let's play bishop g5 let's play bishop
g5 let's again get our bishop to g5 and
maybe this time i do want to take his
knight
this time i kind of do want to take his
knight
okay bishop e6
okay now takes and queen a2 is very
interesting but then black has queen d7
and according to mark you don't really
want to do this unless you can guarantee
that you win material thank you willy
tasks for cash but nonetheless i kind of
want to change the structure a little
bit
okay our opponent taking his time on f
takes c6 good stuff
um
and now let's play queen and swing it
over to a2 and attack e6
hmm the problem is after queen d7 i
don't really see a follow-up
yeah we're i have a very very strong
feeling that we're going to lose this
game let's try to double rooks on the
d-file
let's try to double rooks on the d-file
let's double well rook cd1 he's got
knight d4
um
this is starting to look like one of
those games uh but
okay we gotta handle it in in style
okay let's go rook cd1
yeah and unfortunately black has this
move knight d4 now otherwise we'd
develop some sort of pressure against
the d6 pawn h6
yeah i had to take the draw that's the
thing i i had to take the draw there but
i didn't think that i thought i'd be
able to get away with it little did i
know who i was facing
b6
wow
okay let's play queen b1
and then maybe an ip5
no but now i have 95. now oh but he's
called queen eight of course yeah so we
have to go knight p5 and get it away
from the attack
yeah yeah this is
yeah we know we know what's happening
this is uh i'm
about 90 to 95 percent sure but of
course we will look after the game
it's just one of those games but you can
see by the time consumption you can see
by the way that he's out playing me and
i honestly had a feeling after knight g4
already
the course of the game has only kind of
served to confirm my suspicions
yeah the book is banned it's all because
the smithmore is a terrible opening
that's the reason we're losing this game
right okay let's play 92 knight before
i'm still trying the game is not over
the game is not over i'm still trying we
want to go knight before
we want to create counter play against
the queen side okay let's go knight b4
and then maybe knight d3 and knight
takes e5
if he goes a5
no i think well not taking the bishop
makes sense to me but you know a 1900
would probably have made a couple of
mistakes at this point
okay but now we have knight takes e5 so
wait a second maybe this is not so clear
after all
maybe this is not so clear after all
knight c3
oh my god
okay all right
you win my friend
and he thinks on knight takes a2 which
was of course pretty damning but then
knight takes b6
knight takes b6 knight c3 knight takes
ca i don't know i'm just going to go for
it we got to try to win as many pawns as
possible
yeah this is
very unfortunate it
ruins the mood but
you can't do anything about it he's got
rook takes c8 and at the end of the line
he takes on a3 no he takes on e2
interesting oh my god knight g3
[Laughter]
knight g3 check
i see
how could i have missed that elementary
tactic i mean
he's not even trying to hide it though
that's the problem
these people always puzzle me because
they make it so incredibly obvious
and they expect to last on the site it's
it's pretty crazy to me
yeah mark says he's faced knight g4 only
once and the fact that
you know a random dude does it on
chess.com and plays the super
theoretically topical line that was
already that already threw me off
the thing is i'm going to try to flag
him he's got a little bit too much time
if he had a minute at this point i'd
have a chance
but
unfortunately he's playing too
accurately and he's basically gonna
checkmate me within a couple of moves
rook takes f2 is coming
what's up
yeah
no no of course i mean he's thinking on
rook takes h2
yeah yeah he won't last another day
played the wrong guy
oh knight c3 i mean he's clearly not a
player at all because he's not even
playing on his own in this position
yeah we have zero chemistry i mean the
one
the author of the book comes in to help
me and i still lose to a 1900.
i still lose to a 1900.
you know how you know it's an engine
it's when like the middle game there's
this sense in which you make one little
inaccuracy and then you just get blown
off the board like it's not even close
not a single one of your ideas even
comes close to working so you could kind
of see that there once i declined the
repetition
the game was over it was like
not a single idea worked
and
i'll be completely honest with people
and say that i already knew what the
truth was i i already had a sense when
he played knight g4 like that was the
moment when i could sense that something
was a little bit off oh my god d4 and
then wherever i go he checkmates me
no oh knight f6 m8 beautiful
that's a beautiful mate congratulations
very nice
all right so first first order of
business
i'm gonna report him
all right
yeah okay i'll uh this this this this
guy will not last very long
but it's interesting um
yeah cheaters suck
i mean it just it just sucks how many of
these people there are yeah i'll analyze
anyway we'll look with an engine
um just obviously we will confirm
i violated my golden rule and i reported
to him without actually checking the
game
explicitly but i think everybody can
forgive me for that
so first a quick run through an accuracy
check yeah 95 it seems like is the
accuracy he aims for
he aims for in all of his games
so yeah knight g4 knight back to f6
bishop g4 is best knight takes before
yeah this knight takes before bishop d7
routine was already
highly highly suspicious
yeah i mean
rook
rook 6 c7 look at this move rook 67
prophylaxis against knight before
yeah i mean okay
and then he continued playing like an
engine like here most people would start
playing on their own but not this guy
every move was still perfect
yeah okay so that is probably one of the
most flavoring games we've ever had in
that sense
but yeah the critical position
the critical position
uh comes after before and i know that
mark analyzes this this position in the
book
and knight g4 and knight f6 is part of
an annoying series of lines where
players basically use the fact that they
don't mind a draw
to
force you to essentially either take a
draw
or uh
or or to go for a dubious variation but
let's see if we can find
uh something that's not bishop e3 that
yields
reasonable chances of course the engine
is recommending us to play bishop e3
in this position it appears that there
is an interesting idea to play bishop
take c6 and this is stockfish at a very
low depth so you'll have to analyze this
on your own bishop takes e6f takes c6
and bishop c5
is an interesting try
probably mark is aware of this
and if queen ah but now queen b8
ah and the idea is the bishop is trapped
but white has this move b5
white has this move b5 which opens up a
pathway for the bishop to escape
knight goes back to d8
yeah and probably white is worse here
because the knight re-routes to f7 and
black's pawn mass is going to be very
very well defended it's going to be very
hard to access to access any of the
pawns d6 or e6 here
so this is probably unsound it looks
like white kind of has to go bishop d2
and essentially has to repeat
it's funny because a lot of people i
think at a level of like 17 1800 make a
couple of very typical mistakes like i
see queen c7
is a very tempting move
but immediately white develops this huge
initiative cosine thank you knight b5
and bishop f4 forces e5
and now you play
uh
you know now now you play bishop g5
threatening bishop takes f6 and knight
takes d6
so black has to avoid a bunch of
different pitfalls in this line
in order to get to
this position so e5 bishop e3
now bishop g4 is a very tempting move
but it leaves this bishop on c4 to
operate uncontested and the pin is not
very dangerous as long as the bishop
remains on e3 to defend d4 i think that
is the primary purpose of getting the
bishop out to e3 so mark gives rook ac1
castles h3
now with bishop h5
then you develop
very strong king side play
with g4 and knight h4
i mean pressure is coming from all sides
here
and if black takes on f3 then you get
total domination over the light squares
and what i like about the smith war is
that in the main lines it's actually
rather positional
the compensation isn't purely
you know i'm just trying to checkmate
you and if i don't checkmate you i lose
in some of the lines the compensation is
positional and gives you a chance to
practice your positional skills
um so it's a pretty versatile opening in
the sense that it yeah it allows you to
practice multiple skills
um
and it's interesting bishop h5
g4
yeah and of course bishop h5 g4 and h4
so bishop b6
b4
and now if knight takes b4 the idea is
you play knight takes
c5 and the storm surges
that's the line in the book bishop takes
e6 and queen c4 is coming
knight b5 a lot of different threats in
this position so this is something to
dick around in but yeah knight g4 very
interesting resource
there should be two knight f6 and i
should have repeated
and once i allowed bishop g5 bishop g4 i
correctly played bishop e3
let's see where my further mistakes were
h3 bishop d7
okay so far i'm playing decently all
right looks like bishop g5 should have
been preferred
followed by bishop takes f6 and rook
takes d6 it looks like i should have
gone for
for the d6 pawn
as quickly as possible
still not very good but at least this
would have afforded
some degree of active play
yeah
literally pawn down
here i'm upon down for nothing
unfortunately now two puns down
so yeah a good exercise in theoretical
knowledge this is something that if
you're a sicilian player for black
obviously this line is among the most
reputable against the smith mora
and if you're looking to improve your
positional understanding with white
you know sometime tomorrow you can spend
some time analyzing this position just
analyze it with an engine
find
the games in this line and
learn
learn from the analysis
right it's as simple as that you can
really improve your positional
understanding
just by
casually analyzing certain positions
um and there is oh yeah i forgot to
mention that mark's game actually
continued bishop e6 here instead of
knight f6
bishop b6 fv6 queen c4 hitting hitting
e6
um
or sorry he played knight b4 no no no
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry wrong
position wrong position yeah b4 okay
yeah i was like something feels wrong
here knight g4 and now knight takes b4
knight takes b4 was was mark's game
bishop b6 fp6 queen c4 okay that makes
sense because now you're forking the
knight in the pawn
and now d5 ed5
so
black cannot recapture because the
knight on g4 hangs
so your opponent took on f2
king takes f2 and now made a critical
mistake he played e takes d5 oh and
knight takes d5 i see
yeah the guy found all of the moves
except the last one
so if queen takes d5 you play bishop
takes b4 and you're up a piece and if
knight takes d5 you just move your
bishop away to e3 and the knight cannot
be defended white is winning
so the key was for black to play rook c8
first
the key was for black to play rook c8
first
and of course if the queen moves back to
b3
then you have the fork on d3 but white
has the interesting queen g4 attacking
e6 from the other side
knight d3 check with complete
pandemonium
king f1 knight takes c1 you probably
take here as an intermediate move king 8
shade rook takes c1 and
a very very sharp position where black
has counter play against the black king
and moves like bishop a3 come to mind
but
white's got the material advantage the
past pawn
and you know the potential to
consolidate because all of the pieces
are
nicely placed in the center e4 is being
prevented
and white's king can even walk toward
the center with king e2
yeah
this is exactly why the book is called
mayhem in the more this is mayhem bishop
g5 maybe black should play
but another position that you can
analyze to learn
you know
to learn the art of analysis
it's a very interesting line yeah with
knight takes before but our opponent and
his infinite wisdom
knew to drop the knight back to f6
that's kind of an underrated thing to do
right you just go somewhere then you go
back and the concept that your opponent
has nothing better than to repeat
is a notion that a lot of people have
their have a hard time wrapping their
head around people just don't like going
back and forth but sometimes
you induce a certain move and if your
opponent doesn't go back to the square
that he came from
you know then you are the one who has
benefited
so anyways um hope you enjoyed the
analysis
i'm exhausted i'm gonna call it a night
folks but
thank you everybody for
thank you everybody for a lovely stream
for a great support as usual
thanks for hanging out folks i'll see
everybody later have a good rest of your
night
bye everybody
[Music]